Hey Thoughty2 here.
What took us from living in caves to being
an advanced, multi-lingual, intelligent species?
It has a lot to do with just a handful of
extremely crucial inventions.
Let's take a look at the incredible inventions
that played the biggest parts in advancing
the human race.
1.
Fist up is fire.
Okay it's not strictly an invention, more
a discovery.
But being the first source of warmth for humans,
it's importance cannot go un-noted.
It's estimated that fire was discovered 1.8
million years ago.
And it set the wheels in motion, as it was
the basis for energy for years to come.
2.
Speaking of wheels.
It wasn't until 3,500 BC when humans finally
invented the wheel.
The wheel proved to be such a crucial component
of the advancement of the human race, so why
did it take humans so long to invent it?
I mean by 3500 BC it was already the Bronze
Age, humans were casting metal alloys, building
sailboats and even complex musical instruments
such as the harp.
So what took them so long.
Well the problem with the wheel, was not getting
a cylindrical object to roll on its side,
anyone could do that.
It was attaching that cylinder to a stationary
platform, so it could move freely and independently,
without rolling off down the hill.
This is known as the wheel and axle design,
to achieve this a lot of factors have to be
gotten right.
Such as, the circumference of the axels has
to be perfectly smooth, as does the hole in
the centre of the wheel, otherwise there will
be too much friction and the wheels won't
turn.
Even more challenging, the axels had to fit
snuggly inside the wheels, but not too snuggly
or they won't rotate freely.
Inventors would also need access to very large
slabs of wood from a large tree in order to
carve a large wheel from it.
The wheel was certainly a huge challenge;
all these factors and more are why humans
took so long to invent the wheel.
It's not something that would have happened
overnight and it likely only happened once,
but once it was discovered, it spread very
quickly over the rest of Europe.
The wheel's most likely birthplace was either
Eastern Europe or Mesopotamia, but historians
can't agree on a precise location.
The wheel was so vitally important because
it gave birth to modern day farming, which
made us less nomadic and freed up people's
time so they could focus on discovering new
inventions.
3.
Imagine you're far out at sea, traveling to
a far off land, the ocean currents are pulling
your boat in every direction, you no longer
know which way is north, south, east or west,
you have nothing but your boat to guide you.
What happens?
You will probably end up going gravely off
course, or even more likely just go round
and round in circles for days, until you run
out of water and die at sea.
This was what happened to many a sailor in
the thousands of years between the invention
of the boat and a navigational device.
The world was full of people getting lost
at sea and the whole thing was a bloody mess.
Until the 11th century when Han dynasty China
invented the very first maritime compass.
The first compass used a lodestone, which
is a naturally magnetised iron ore.
The compass quickly spread throughout the
rest of the world via maritime contact.
And so finally people could safely traverse
the seas, and travel far away from their homelands
to distant new worlds, opening up new trade
routes and starting the Age of Discovery.
4.
Knowledge is power.
It was the desire for knowledge that took
us from being hunter gatherers to where we
are now.
Nothing excels the technological advancement
of a species more than the sharing of knowledge.
But in the 15th century how would you go about
sharing knowledge?
There's no internet or phones.
So people relied on books.
But for many centuries books had to be painstakingly
hand written, one by one.
This meant book were very expensive and knowledge
was severely limited for the majority of the
population and for a long time this proved
to be a major brick wall, standing in the
way of the progress of mankind.
What was really needed was an abundance of
books so human knowledge could be shared freely
and quickly.
And that's what the much needed printing press
gave to the human race when it was invented
in the 15th century.
Although the first movable type system was
created in 11th century Song Dynasty China,
the complexity of the Chinese writing system
stopped it from gaining much traction.
It wasn't until the 15th century when Johannes
Gutenberg invented the first western movable
type printing press in Germany, that the idea
of mass printing really caught on.
Gutenberg cast individual letters and punctuation
marks out of various metals, which was a vast
improvement on the Chinese system that used
wooden blocks.
Gutenberg's printing press exponentially increased
the speed at which copies of books could be
made, which led to a rapid increase in the
spread of knowledge across Europe.
5.
In 1859 a Belgian engineer called Étienne
Lenoir created one of the most revolutionary
pieces of engineering to date, the internal
combustion engine.
This engineering masterpiece replaced the
dated steam engine to become the de-facto
standard for powering the world's machinery
and transportation systems.
The internal combustion engine works by burning
fuel in a combustion chamber, the high pressure
gas which is created then pushes a piston,
thereby transforming chemical energy into
useful mechanical energy.
The internal combustion engine gave birth
to countless modern technologies but most
notably modern cars and aircraft.
6.
Next up is the telephone.
Although it had many pioneers it was Alexander
Graham Bell who was awarded the first patent
for the electric telephone in 1876.
Bell's goal was to make a telephone that was
affordable to everyone, before this electric
communication such as the electric telegraph
were horrendously expensive and were only
used by the very wealthy.
Bell changed this, and very soon there was
a telephone in nearly every home, business
and learning institution.
This enabled instantaneous communication and
revolutionised the way we communicate with
the rest of the world.
The telephone catalysed international business
and accelerated human learning.
In later years the telephone system would
also become the building blocks for the internet.
7.
Next up is the very foundation that powers
the entire world we live in today, electricity.
Human's have always been aware of electricity
and its power.
Ancient Egyptian texts dating back to 2750
BC talk about people getting shocks from electric
fish such as Catfish and the Electric Ray.
But it wasn't until Thomas Edison created
the first practical, long-lasting electric
light bulb in 1879, that electricity transformed
from being just a scientific curiosity to
an essential tool for modern life.
Following Edison's invention a whole multitude
of other electrical devices quickly followed
in the years to come.
Nothing has altered the face of technology
like the discovery and practical applications
of electrical power.
8.
In 1928 a Scottish scientist called Alexander
Fleming was experimenting with bacteria in
his laboratory when he discovered something
that would change the world.
He noticed that one of his petri dishes filled
with bacteria had become contaminated with
mould, and everywhere the mould had spread
the bacteria was dead.
What was this mysterious mould that had the
ability to stop bacteria dead in its tracks,
it turned out to be a fungus called Penicillium.
Over the next two decades chemists purified
the fungus and eventually turned it into the
drug penicillin, the worlds first antibiotic.
Penicillin proved to be the magic bullet for
a whole load of previously deadly diseases,
this new miracle cure could fight off infections
without doing any harm to most humans.
Fleming's discovery forever changed the way
we treat diseases.
9.
British mathematician and inventor Charles
Babbage invented the first computer in the
year 1832 it contained processors which Babbage
called "mills" and a memory which he called
the "store", just like in modern computers.
But unfortunately Babbage was way ahead of
his time, it wouldn't be until over 100 years
later in 1971 when the world's first personal
computer was manufactured and sold.
It was called the Kenbak-1 and sold for $750.
Ever since then computer technology has accelerated
at an unprecedented rate and subsequently
so has human knowledge and our technological
accomplishments.
Just like the abacus did thousands of years
ago, the personal computer outsourced the
task of complex mathematics and problem solving
to machines.
The computer was so influential to human development
that it accelerated us into a brand new age,
the information age.
10.
And finally, you can't talk about the personal
computer, without, of course talking about
the internet.
No other invention has shaped the way we go
about our daily lives, as much as the internet.
We now heavily rely on the internet for shopping,
business, relationships, entertainment, creativity
and general human communications.
English computer scientist Sir Tim Berners-Lee
invented the World Wide Web in 1989 whilst
working at CERN, he then wrote the very first
HTTP web client and server in 1990.
Berners-Lee also founded the World Wide Web
Consortium, which is responsible for maintaining
the international standards for URLs, HTTP,
HTML and CSS, or to put it more simply, the
technology that the entire internet runs on.
We still use those same standards and technologies
to this day.
So, in a movement that could be considered
both scary and exciting at the very same time,
the internet changed human kind like nothing
before it, and as the internet and the way
we use it evolves every year, so too, does
the human race.
Thanks for the view, subscribe for more Thoughty2.